a few years ago I had a corporate
feminist dream job launching a company's
national initiative to recruit more
female employees in the finance sector
but first I had to get the signed off
support of all department heads so I
spent months perfecting the proposal
presented it and won the support of
almost everyone but in this team there
were two men we'll call Howard and Tom
Howard just would not get back to me I
emailed him about the proposal I left
him voicemails I'd roll my chair back
and forth during meetings trying to make
eye contact with Howard he'd just take
out his phone and start scrolling and
then I started to question myself had I
been diplomatic enough in that email too
demanding in that voicemail does Howard
hate this proposal or am I just
overreacting it's probably just me I
thought and then one day I'm walking
down the hall and here comes Howard he's
holding a packet of papers sees me and
lights up he says Sarah Tom just emailed
this to me
you should take a look it's a proposal
for us to recruit more women I think tom
is a really great idea here and we
should all get behind it Howard proceeds
to hand my own proposal back to me and
explains to me the many merits of what I
wrote
Howard was never against recruiting more
women but he needed to hear from a man
why it was important to hire more woman
and as this scene played out I said
nothing
because I knew somehow that I was a
guest in a place that wasn't meant for
me and so instead of questioning my
environment I questioned myself I wanted
to know how so many talented woman who
worked long hours and started their
careers with confidence all became
trained in this kind of self-doubt that
makes them say it's probably just me how
is that still possible aren't things
getting better opportunities for women
have increased over the last 50 years
but over the last decade progress is
stalled experts have previously
identified 2059
as the year the wage gap would close but
in September of this year
these same experts announced that
according to the most current data we'll
have to adjust our expectations to the
year 21 19 101 years from now looking
beyond the wage gap women are still
underrepresented in leadership receive
less access to senior leaders and are
leaving the fastest-growing sectors such
as tech at forty five percent higher
rates than men citing culture as the
primary reason so what have we been
doing to address gender inequality why
isn't it working
many businesses think they're addressing
the problem because they provide
training eight billion dollars worth of
training a year according to studies
from the Harvard Business Review the
same studies also conclude that these
trainings don't work an often backfire
research tracking the hiring and
promotion practices of
800 30 companies over the course of 30
years found that white men who are asked
to go to tighter diversity trainings
tend to rebel by hiring and promoting
fewer women and fewer minorities the
other solution has been to ask women to
change their own behavior to lean in to
sit at the table negotiate as often as
men oh and get more training women
currently earned the majority of college
degrees outperform their peers in key
leadership skills and are running
businesses that outperform the
competition it doesn't look like
education or skills or business acumen
are the problem
we're already empowered enough to make
an impact on the businesses that are
ready these approaches fail to address
the key systemic problem unconscious
bias
[Applause]
[Music]
we all have bias it's okay it's lodged
in our amygdala it keeps ticking away
when we go to work
bias affects how much I like you would I
believe you're capable of and even how
much space I think you take up thanks in
part to the me to movement awareness of
gender bias has spread but the
harassment stories that made headlines
are just one piece you don't have to
harass a woman to limit her career the
messages women sent me aren't about
being harassed they're being tolerated
in the workplace but they're not being
valued I don't know anyone who's ever
said you know what I love about my
employer they just tolerate me so well
I feel so tolerated to break the inertia
we need to take a step beyond me to
beyond just being tolerated as women our
organization decided to tackle the
problem in two ways first if we're all
bias our workplaces need to be actively
anti-bias by design not by trying to
change mindsets one training at a time
so our team began by identifying over
100 cultural levers that can be adjusted
to counter the impact of bias we found
that small tweaks can lead to big
changes and they cost a lot less than
eight billion dollars so what do these
small tweaks look like if a woman is
asked to state her gender before filling
out a job application or performing a
skills related test she performs worse
than if she were not asked first so how
can businesses avoid activating this
self stereotyping bias move the gender
checkbox to the end of the application
example two in a national survey that we
conducted men were 50% more likely to
state they had
saved multiple frequent evaluations over
the course of the last year as opposed
to one single yearly review here's why
this matters
Fortune magazine reviewed performance
evals across industries and found that
criticism like this related to
personality but not job-related skills
appeared in 71 of the ninety-four yearly
reviews received by women of the 83
reviews received by men personality
criticism showed up twice but in
businesses that conduct much shorter
highly frequent reviews say five-minute
weekly evaluations focused on specific
projects the personality criticism
vanishes and the perceived performance
gap between men and women is nearly
non-existent while yearly reviews rely
on overall impressions which are like
petri dishes for bias short objectively
focused evaluations eliminate this
feelings based gray area now some
businesses are consciously taking these
steps to counter the impact of bias
while others just do a good job of
advertising we've wanted to find out
who's actually getting it right so we
put a poll on Facebook we asked women in
workshops how they were choosing
employers where they would be valued the
most common response that we heard I
google it
so we googled it specifically we googled
best employers for women in tech our
results showed three completely
different lists one business shows up as
the top employer on one list doesn't
show up at all on another some lists
offer no criteria and some are purchased
ads they're paid for employees and
employers both want clear benchmarks
that go beyond good intentions the lead
certification
gave businesses this clear
around environmental stewardship by
outlining the exact steps they need to
take for certification we wanted
businesses to have this kind of playbook
for gender equity so for our second act
we took what we have learned from
testing these cultural levers we
partnered with University of Washington
and created the first standardized
certification for gender equity and us
businesses
[Applause]
[Music]
to create this standard we had to learn
what matters and what doesn't we found
out that what matters is not the total
percentage of female employees or the
number of board members that are female
those are what we call vanity metrics
they can be bought
while the culture inside can still be
out of balance the factors that matter
and that should be measured are under
the surface for example even in
organizations were equal percentages of
women and men state that they have had
access to a mentor men's mentors are
more likely to be in senior positions
reviewing our survey results men were
twice as likely to state they have been
offered an opportunity to shadow someone
in a senior role we're all used to
hearing about the wage gap hidden
opportunity gaps like these are just as
influential so when assessing a
company's culture we measure these gaps
between men's and women's experiences
and the smaller the gap the more equity
Center the culture we also searched our
findings for the tenants of workplace
culture that are most important to men
and most important to women we learned
that only three factors consistently
mattered to men while a doesn't matter
to women and the only share one in
common topping the list for a woman paid
family leave health care for dependents
and feeling that their ideas are heard
and they're properly credited for them
these are a few of the hundred eighty
eight indicators that determine whether
or not an organization meets our
quantitative standard for workplace
equality based on the data that matter
these are the factors to create a
culture of equity that lasts not just
for a month or for a quarter but for
years so where does this leave us
one
in the workforce today are constantly
told you can be anything you want now
it's up to you women of color for whom
the wage gap is even larger have heard
it the two thirds of minimum-wage
workers who are women have heard it
workers who don't identify as male or
female and hide their identity at work
have heard it if they can hear you can
be anything you want now it's up to you
I believe it's time for our businesses
to hear it too
eliminating workplace bias is a tall
order but we can't afford to let half
our people go on being ignored
we've given businesses a framework for
real change businesses can be anything
they want now it is up to them thank you
[Applause]